une championne de la croissance à
montigny le bretonneux la pme à terme s
affiche un taux moyen de 46 2% par an
une réussite pour cette entreprise
spécialisée dans des produits de haute
technologie destinées aux industriels de
la sécurité défense
cette croissance elle est due à aux
investissements que nous avons faits en
recherche et développement et
l'accompagnement que nous avons eu quand
même des clients qui nous font confiance
et puis alors à la motivation du
personnel
créé en 1989 cette pme est venu
s'installer à montigny le bretonneux
notamment pour se rapprocher de ses
clients comme thales eads ou mbd à des
donneurs d'ordres exigeant qui nécessite
de la main d'oeuvre très qualifiée est
difficile à trouver
c'est le savoir-faire c'est l'ancienneté
de leur de la société aussi donc sa
pérennité sans savoir faire on a
énormément de collaborateurs extrêmement
compétents nous pourrions embauché à peu
près 10 ou 15 personnes supplémentaires
si on les avait tout de suite par
rapport à notre chiffre d'affaires et à
nos carnets de commandes s'est vraiment
que quoi autre facteur de croissance le
développement de leur propre gamme de
produits à l'export 20% du chiffre
d'affaires est réinvesti dans la
recherche et développement ce qui
représente 6 millions d'euros en 2015
notamment pour développer ce système de
surveillance aux frontières et de sites
stratégiques destinés à l'exportation
dans le marché export très clairement
nous travaillons avec des grands
donneurs d'ordre de la défense notre
client le plus important est un client
chinois qui s'appelle norinco prochaine
étape poursuivre le développement de ses
produits pour passer d'un statut de pme
à celui d'entreprises de taille
intermédiaire